international aid agencies are sounding
the alarm over the situation
in the northern ethiopian region off to
grai
they were allowed to deliver some
supplies at the start of the week but
they say they need
full humanitarian access to the region
if they are to save lives
the fear is that millions of people in
tegra do not have enough to eat or drink
and that the area is on the brink of a
humanitarian disaster
following the recent conflict there now
tens of thousands have fled
the hostilities into grai as we report
many of them are now in sudan
and they are also in dire need
the umbra cuba refugee camp in sudan
one of several camps scattered along
sudan's border to ethiopia
they're filling up with people fleeing
the conflict in the neighbouring tigrai
region
we were in a refugee camp and then we
came here
we've been here for a week there aren't
enough tents or enough water
and we're exposed to the sun most of the
time
[Music]
the un says aid groups are struggling to
care for the influx of refugees
the remoteness of the camps is also a
problem
in the first two weeks they took care of
us but after that no one came again
a truck comes with food twice a day but
other than that there's nothing
they haven't even registered us yet
the refugees torn between the threat of
violence in tigrai
and the grim reality of the camp
thanks be to god i'm with my daughters
here who take care of me
there's nothing here to make me happy as
a refugee
this isn't a life at all but thanks to
the lord
at least i'm here with my daughters
refugees continue to pour into the camps
in sudan
despite ethiopia's prime minister abby
ahmed
declaring victory into grime more than
two weeks ago
those at the camp hope they can soon
return
meanwhile in tagrai aid is starting to
trickle in
the first trucks arrived carrying red
cross medical supplies earlier this week
huge teamwork to upload all the items
either red cross volunteers
uploaded in motion for the systems
of the population in the region
but millions in tigrai remain out of
reach of aid
as the conflict leaves hunger in its
wake
[Music]
for more i'm now joined by the ethiopian
american author and writer maza
miningista her new novel
the shadow king was shortlisted for the
booker prize the books about italy's
invasion of ethiopia in 1935. welcome to
dw news africa
maza i do want to begin by asking you
about the current conflicts in your
country of birth
the u.n said that the world is watching
the unfolding of a full-scale
humanitarian crisis
how does that make you feel
well you know this has been really
it's a distressing um it's been a
distressing
event to watch this from afar
uh to know that there are entire
groups of people that are being left
destitute
that people's hopes and dreams for their
families
are being destroyed and people
themselves are dying
it's uh it's been a horrible month
um and you know the fact that the world
is watching
it feels like uh this is also
um a part of this war part of everything
that has been happening in 2020
earlier is information versus
transformation
your latest novel the shadow king tell
us more about
your using fiction to tell the story of
how ethiopians fought the italians
during the invasion
uh you know um i i was
interested in looking at what war can
tell us about
uh human beings the human condition
what war can reveal about our fears our
love
our ambitions our dreams the war that
took place in 1935 when
italy invaded ironically italy invaded
and around the region that is being
um that is at in conflict today
so i've been looking at what's happening
in 2020 and thinking very much
about the way that war was fought on the
same grounds in 1935.
now the main protagonist uh uh in in the
shadow king is a woman the
the other main characters are also women
why was this important for you to do
i wanted to think about the fact that
when we speak about
war when we speak of conflict we imagine
men we imagine soldiers as men
and yet women and girls are directly
affected by war and in ethiopia in 1935
they understood that and they went to
the front lines
in order to have their own say in in the
way that their country
and their future went and i wanted to
portray that
because we don't talk enough about the
active role of women in in
in war the book's due for release in
italy early next year tell us why you're
particularly looking forward to that
well uh i've done so much research in in
italy it's this this history is
italian history but it's also a history
that uh most of italy
either doesn't know about or feels very
uncomfortable
in addressing and i welcome the
conversations that will happen
there and i am eager to join the
the dialogue that has been started by
other italians already
this is a history that was supposed to
be forgotten
violence um of that invasion in 1935 is
a strong theme in the no
in the novel do you think that ethiopia
has healed from that do you think it
will heal
from the conflict that's currently
raging
ethiopia has not healed from 1935
ethiopia had not had a chance
to to talk about that history to italy
has never apologized
for the human the crimes against
humanity
that they enacted on ethiopians at that
time
um in 1935 there was a war fought in
ethiopia in 1974 there was a revolution
that came
some of those people alive in 35 had to
contend with revolution in 74.
1974 to 2000 you know to 2020
people have those memories too so what
we're seeing is a layering
of memory and pain and trauma and
violence
and we haven't dealt with it yet that's
mazza
many guest ethiopian american writer and
author
of the shadow king thank you masa
thank you